failed former president Donald Trump
indicted 34 counts reportedly Donald
Trump expected to be in New York City in
court on Tuesday to be booked mugshotted
fingerprinted arraigned and subsequently
released Donald Trump has absolutely
lost his mind posting the entire night
to truth social we will look at that
many of you agree with me that Trump
will not see the inside of a prison self
or even one day but that being said this
shows that no one is above the law so
many people saying this is unprecedented
and this is not Justice no no no no no
no
if Trump was above the law that would
not be Justice and he will get his day
in court he is innocent until proven
guilty and I believe that this first
indictment out of New York City may be
the first of many with prosecutors
waiting to see will someone be the first
to indict a former president the
Associated Press reports Donald Trump
indicted expected to surrender early
next week the exact nature of the
charges is unclear as of Friday
because the indictment remains under
seal but they stem from payments made
during the 2016 campaign to silence the
claims of an extramarital sexual
encounter of course with Stormy Daniels
Trump has assailed the uh entire thing
says it's all bogus and nonsense this is
historic in every single way Donald
Trump wildly posting to truth social all
night I'm scrolling it for people to see
multiple times per hour three hours ago
and then going to
eventually a lot of posts three hours
ago then eventually getting to seven
hours ago which would have put it at 3
30 in the morning and nine hours ago 1
30 just posting posting I I'm gonna stop
scrolling because people are going to
get dizzy Donald Trump initially
reacting to the indictment with a
misspelled Post in which he says he has
been indicated not only is this the
first time that a former president has
been indicated by a grand jury this is
the first time a grand jury has
indicated any president and of course it
is beyond parody that even this Trump
can't string together a reasonable
statement about Trump posting to truth
quote the and by the way there's capital
letters all over this thing I'm not even
going to mention each time Trump
randomly capitalizes these thugs in
radical left monsters have just
indicated the 45th president of the
United States of America and the leading
Republican candidate by far for the 2024
nomination for president here he engages
caps lock and says this is an attack on
our country the likes of which has never
been seen before
remember Trump was a one-man crime spree
as president the likes of which the
country has never seen before Trump
continuing in all capital letters it is
likewise A continuing attack on our once
free and fair elections no it's not the
USA is now a third world nation a nation
in serious decline so sad then Trump
putting out a more formal statement
which was no less unhinged I won't read
the entire thing I'm not going to
subject you to that but in the first
paragraph of course he calls the
prosecution a political persecution as
well as election interference he
includes the term Witch Hunt and many
other things in the second paragraph he
says wrongly that Democrats cheated and
have stolen of course it was Trump who
tried to steal the 2020 election in the
third paragraph he says this has never
been done in Nations history that's true
but remember there has never been a
one-man crime spree like Trump in the
Oval Office in American history there
has never been a President Who
surrounded himself
with so many reliably crooked people
then he attacks Alvin Bragg linking him
to George Soros and lastly he says this
will backfire on Joe Biden of course Joe
Biden has nothing to do with it Tuesday
booking an arraignment expected you know
on Tuesday big strong guy with tears in
his eyes might go up to Trump and say
sir I'll be taking your mug shot now
please don't do anything stupid this
shows no one is above the law that is
Justice although Trump will not serve a
day of prison time the hope is that this
is only the beginning
Fox News
melting down over the Trump indictment
you know we deal with a lot of serious
things on this show and Trump's
indictment is serious because it has to
do with no one being above the law but I
would be lying if I didn't admit
that it was a delightful pleasure to see
live on our stream yesterday Fox News
melting down check out this compilation
from Media Matters cat Abu this is just
it's really a delight I don't know how
else to say it Democrats are branding
Trump as a criminal it's legally
pathetic it's clickbait it is an
unbelievable abuse of Justice pure
Balderdash my heart is broken I had some
tears in my eyes we found the guy folks
we found the big strong guy with tears
in his eyes it's this guy Lou gellermino
a criminal defense attorney is broken I
had some tears in my eyes looking a
little emotional I feel the same way if
there's a mug shot of Donald Trump it'll
be in dorm rooms and on shirts he is an
OG even if convicted that's not going to
stop him Donald Trump could run in park
on saying I'm going to Pardon myself and
go after uh the Deep State there you go
Jonathan Turley man that Turley really
has hit his reputation is just in the
toilet at this point uh the Deep State
it's not open for a debate that we live
in a police state it's like Stalin's
purges we're Crossing the Rubicon here
this is a political Rubicon that has
been crossed they have crossed the
Rubicon basically it's one party hunting
another it almost feels like they're
pushing the population to react it is
they were unconservative
that's Mark Levin by the way screaming
at the top of his lungs there it's it's
really wild stuff react it is
and that's all I'll say about that yeah
now in terms of all of this stuff of the
people aren't going to accept this and
blah blah blah and it's be people better
be careful
if they are insisting that the
indictment of trump is going to set the
country Ablaze and people are going to
rip it apart in Civil War and all of
this stuff the only obvious follow-up
question to that is who are the
individuals that are going to do that
and how do you know that they are going
to do it because what they are saying is
Maga is going to do all those things
you'd better be careful because of Maga
getting violent you'd better be careful
because they the Maga people will rip
the country apart now the upside of this
is
so far we're closing in on 24 hours into
this thing
it doesn't actually seem like the Maga
people care enough to even go out and
protest that's the amazing thing and I
hope there is no violence but for all of
these clowns saying this is going to be
a really bad thing it's going to be
Uprising you're saying the trumpists
will be violent because the progressives
who like seeing Justice why would they
go in protest we're just going to follow
the story
incredible stuff that is going on and
you really do love to see it we found
another guy with tears in his eyes
Republican senator Lindsey Graham
who has debased himself humiliatingly
over the last six years
was tearing up on Fox news last night
it does not get much better than this
here is Lindsay crying about Trump's
indictment
wow how do you do it you take a well if
you got a pile of crap and he'd chop it
up 34 times it's still a pile of crap
it's duplicious charging I think by
duplicious he meant means duplicitous or
duplicative
it's very unclear what he's talking
about but he is all teary a pile of crap
is to push charging they're trying to
smear the guy they're trying to take
cases that nobody else would take and
resurrect them this is literally legal
Voodoo folks
it
I really hope that this is the first of
many indictments I really do if Lindsay
is this broken up and triggered by the
first one which is arguably the most
minor one what's happening in Georgia is
potentially far more disastrous for
Trump than this just you wait until we
get to the next one so Lindsay not
having a good one let's briefly talk now
about Eric Trump
Donald Trump was indicted he will be
indicted the jury voted to indict he
will be arraigned on Tuesday within
couple hours Donald Trump's I guess
least favorite son Eric Trump goes on
Fox News and he reacts to the indictment
by ranting about CVS and Tylenol now you
might be saying David wait I know about
Advil I know about Tylenol what's
Tylenol I also don't know but here is
Eric Trump ranting about CVS and Tylenol
in response to his dad's indictment meet
us every single day and this is a city I
spent a lot of time in Europe that is
falling apart I went into literally CVS
the other day and you can't buy Tylenol
because it's locked behind these glass
counters because there's so much theft
and there's so much looting there's so
much homelessness and crime but yet
their attention is going after Donald
Trump little girl yeah so listen first
of all you go into CVS or you go into
Walgreens anywhere in this country when
I was just recently in Florida I went in
I had to get my very powerful hair
product it's locked up I had to ask
could you pretty please with the key
open it up for me you go into a CVS
North of New York City as I recently did
and uh the deodorant my girlfriend's
deodorant it's like you know everything
free it's free of soy it's free of of
beef broth there's no beef broth it's
you know one of these hipster uh
deodorants it's locked up somehow I
don't think that that's really the
alternative for Alvin Bragg to be
focusing on
compared to the Trump indictment what I
would suggest to Eric Trump is maybe
hold off on these pathetic appearances
because you you really seem unhinged and
you literally went to CVS what does that
mean as opposed to you sent someone I
don't even know what this guy is talking
about lock in folks because what we are
going to see over the next let me think
24 48 so over the next 96 hours leading
up to the Trump arraignment is going to
be increasingly unhinged and the hope is
and I'm not you know people write in and
say David you're hoping that Maga
becomes violent no no no no no no no I
didn't want violence on January 6th I'm
against violence I don't want violence I
don't want shootings I don't want
burning I don't want looting I don't
want any of it don't no matter who's
doing it
I hope
that Maga doesn't get violent over this
so far they really don't seem to care
and even when Trump previously said I'm
getting arrested on Tuesday which didn't
happen on that day
um his supporters really didn't seem to
be activating the way he wanted them to
so let's all hope cooler heads prevail
as Justice proceeds let's hope this is
the first of many indictments we're
going to take a break what a day what a
day
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David pakman show is of course made
possible day in and day out by our
members membership is cheap it's quick
and it feels good you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and know that unlike your
cable subscription from which four bugs
a month go to Fox News uh all but 2.9
percent of every dollar which goes to
just swiping the credit cards and debit
cards comes directly to us sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount let's go to the phones my
friends we are going to hear from the
most important people
to the show which are the people in the
audience we do these calls via Discord
at davidpackman.com
Discord as a reminder you have to
request to speak if you would like to
chat with me very important in order to
be called on your name must be in the
format of name and location or location
and name so people with jokes or
nicknames or you know obvious stuff like
that you won't be called on
so typically the names would be
something like for example Harry from
Columbus Ohio that's the first person to
join us today Harry welcome to the show
what's on your mind today
David can you hear me I can hear you
beautifully
that's Pleasant last time my audio was
well it was at hacked by antify I have
no other way to put it really they
pronounce it antifa now it's pronounced
antifa so
um you said recently you're back in the
gym now I want to just say one thing
please if you said that you run before
you lift just I do and I'm wondering I'm
wondering if you're gonna tell I have
read that it's better to lift first
because then you're at maximum strength
and then do your cardio
absolutely that is
the only tweak I have I hear you're
hitting the weights I won't ask you how
or in what specific way I'll let you get
into that detail when you're ready of
course well I'm ready right now I mean I
don't know what you're sharing uh listen
do you enjoy it listen I'm not like some
kind of uh I I'm not Reinventing the
wheel here you know it's like I have
found I I look online and I say okay if
I'm doing a mix of cardio and weights
and in total I want to be doing four
days a week what's the best mix to do
and it's like oh okay on this day do
rowing machine and then do arms and then
the next day you can do legs and then
run or you know whatever it's just like
I kind of just I just try to stay
organized in that way
yeah it's good to have a split I think
that's what it's formally called oh
where you split up what lifts you're
doing you know it seems like you're
doing a sort of body part bass split
which is can work for beginners I think
it's an excellent choice now if I
weren't a beginning when does the split
stop at what point
I think when you're when you're ready to
move on to something new when you're
saying okay I don't think this is giving
me the returns or when you learn new
information for example I think is a
good way to learn like when I realized
you know I'm not really hitting certain
muscles that I could that's when I you
know changed things up started switching
from a back barbell squat to a front
barbell squat wow you know you gotta you
got to look for these things well listen
Harry I'm not there quite yet but I do
appreciate the um the the check-in and
I'm gonna keep going okay
okay thanks for taking my call I just
have one more quick question and you can
answer it as briefly as you want to when
you I I listened to your interview with
Patrick Bet David I listened to the one
Sam Cedar had with him last week I think
you guys both did an excellent job
dismantling his lazy right-wing points
I'll put it
um but my question is how do you have
the like the confidence like I don't
want to say like media training-esque
feel to how you approach these guys but
what do you do mentally to just steady
yourself keep keep positive stay you
know on top of all your talking points
counter theirs what is the mentality I
really don't do any special prep I just
try to have my normal routine for the
day you know what I mean so like don't
because that what I find is like that
the Patrick Bet David thing is like in
the morning right if I shake up my
routine and like don't have the
breakfast I would normally have or
whatever if my routine is thrown off I
won't feel prepared so I think it's just
like maintaining my routine basically
and getting enough sleep
oh and he's gone oh where did it go all
right I hope I hope my answer was
satisfactory let's go next to Dev from
Syracuse New York Dev welcome to the
David Pacman show what's on your mind
today
hi David uh I've got a question for you
sure can you hear me all right I can
hear you fine
all right well uh Syracuse I don't know
if you know much about Syracuse Upstate
New York uh it is a pretty mixed place
but probably a little more leaning to
the right okay in general uh lots of
suburbs uh and and Country farmer areas
um so I would describe myself as a
progressive independent and I know
titles are a difficult thing but um I
recently became a firearm owner okay and
uh I was wondering um
what your opinion is on personal firearm
use in the context of a tool that might
be used for some things in the future I
kind of look at it like an EpiPen right
it's something that I never want to use
I'm not really a hunter but I want to
have it available in a situation that
may occur where it would be useful well
listen you bring up a really interesting
point and I've had a I have a lot of
friends who are progressive gun owners
many many friends
I've opted never to talk on the show
about whether or not I own firearms like
I've made it clear I support certain
rules and I've said we have a second
amendment but we we have to do something
about the gut like people know my but
I've sort of like stopped short of
saying exactly like what I do or don't
have just because it doesn't there
doesn't seem to be any advantage to that
and if I said exactly what I do or don't
have I just don't know there's any wind
there but one thing that is very very
um compelling to me is
any scenario that is a hypothetical
scenario
that comes up in which the right Wingers
have all or most of the guns that
doesn't sound good even if I think we
are much better off reducing the number
of firearms out there by 95 percent
uh and and like for example even if we
could limit them to people who
demonstrate that they're for hunting use
or it's for target shooting and you keep
it at the range in a safe that's there
or if you can demonstrate an actual need
for self-defense not the vague I've got
50 like okay maybe that would be the the
ideal thing reduce the number of guns
out there by 95 we don't have that
situation and therefore I don't really
love the idea of the right Wingers
having all the guns and what you're
talking about the these contingency
scenarios
make a lot of sense to me in terms of a
motivation to say I want to own some
firearms you know New York is uh I don't
know all of the gun laws across the
country but it seems like New York is
one of the most uh
strict gun laws uh areas in any of the
states and I definitely think that uh
that's a good thing uh running into
roadblocks when you're trying to
purchase a firearm uh even as a you know
a safe uh normal citizen so to speak I
think is is a good thing it shouldn't be
easy to get a firearm I agree and listen
in New York City I'll just say it this
way
I have experienced you know I I it could
be for friends I have experienced the
New York City process for the handgun
permit and it's not easy but it is
possible and if you do it right then
it's a permit that you're able to get
let me ask you just this one uh related
question and I'll let you go I had seen
an idea that I think could appeal to the
right wing as well after they get over
the fact that uh you know it's a change
which is difficult for them to process
um it was essentially uh like a an
evolving gun license where for each
firearm that you wanted to own or even
just fire if you had to qualify on that
particular firearm and therefore that
license would almost be like uh like
collecting it would tap into that kind
of psyche of collecting and you could
that's a super interesting idea that's a
super interesting commercial commercial
pilots have to qualify on the planes
that they fly I think that's a super
interesting idea Dev from Syracuse great
to hear from you very very interesting
let's go next to John in Sharpsville
John in Sharpsville welcome to the David
Pacman show what's on your mind today
John in Sharpsville I've invited you to
participate you do need to accept my
invitation it was going so well today
until we got to John in Sharpsville
all right well I guess we're not going
to hear
from him let's go to Thai from Iowa Thai
from Iowa welcome to the program what
can I do for you today hello David can
you hear me yes I can it sounds like
you're probably on speakerphone but it's
good enough that I won't make a big deal
out of it oh I'm using a Blue Yeti mic
Blue Yeti oh wow okay interesting all
right well please proceed sir
okay so I wanted to bring this up just
because I've been kind of thinking about
it so I know that you have said before
that the right wing in Europe has more
in common with the Democratic party in
America and they deal with the
Republican party I've said that
what I have said what I have said is
that mainstream Democrats in the U.S are
certainly cert centrists in most of
Europe and even center right in some of
Europe
I see I see but I was just gonna say
unfortunately it doesn't seem like
that's the case everywhere so
um there if uh so I would kind of
consider the Democratic party to kind of
be globally more center right
and the Republican Party Moore's hyper
partisan or even far right okay and it's
obviously not as nearly as common as in
other countries but we've seen in Brazil
with bolsonaro who's sometimes called
the Trump of the tropics and their his
supporters rioted and uh Brasilia at the
free Towers Plaza and we've seen in
Hungary with Orban and
Italy with Maloney I think is her name
right Maloney Maloney yeah
yeah
so how do you think things like these
kind of start and how dangerous would
you say these types of movements are for
other countries like we've already seen
Russia turn into a dictatorship you're
saying how how does what start
like how do these
how do these these kind of populist
right-wing movements kind of just form
and just kind of take people over well
so here's the thing as that it's often
starts with
the employment of populist rhetoric by
badly intentioned individuals and this
is why I've said before populist
rhetoric can be a dangerous thing
because right-wing populists and
left-wing populists will say very
similar things but then when they get
into power they do very different things
and so with a lot of these situations it
really is a populist rhetoric by a
would-be authoritarian that the people
fall for sometimes they fall for it in a
context where things are already very
bad in the country Venezuela Russia
other places
um and so I think it it really starts
with the rhetoric at least in places
that are at least superficially
democratically elected if that makes
sense
yeah I got it I feel like a lot of the
stuff can't be done without populism
unfortunately I think yeah and remember
populism is a rhetoric it's not a policy
proposal Tucker Carlson and Bernie agree
the middle class is really getting
screwed in this country Bernie thinks
it's by uh you know corporations and
elected officials who do nothing for
them Tucker is like they're getting
screwed by like BLM and looters and
brown people from Mexico right so they
both are like the middle class is
getting screwed very different ideas as
to how we deal with it yeah I'm just
really kind of hoping that every single
time one of these people doesn't get
their way yeah they're going to urge
their supporters to do violence I really
hope that's not going to be a thing but
it just it happened twice it's really
weird that it's happened twice I hope
not as well I'm with you Ty yeah all
right thank you for the call very much
appreciate it thank you let's go next to
Jason from Mount Juliet Jason from Mount
Juliet welcome to the program
hey David thanks for having me pleasure
I actually wanted to ask you about the
tweet from earlier this week sure um
that you're getting a little bit of heat
from a little bit yeah yeah a little bit
so I honestly think that overall it was
pretty
pretty rough but at the same time you
made a very valid point because there
has to be something done beyond what the
typical response has been right and let
me say just because you're here and by
the way you're in Tennessee
I am you know what I there have been
people who could like Candace Owens
keeps hammering on why won't I apologize
so it's like well listen I'm not going
to apologize for the statement I made
which was thoughts and prayers don't
stop school shootings we need to do more
however what I did learn Jason is that
even though anyone in my audience when
they see the Tweet they go David's not
blaming kids for getting shot he's
blaming the people who don't do anything
other than thoughts and prayers my
audience gets it that sarcasm doesn't
translate well number one to people who
don't already know me and number two to
people who might understand that it's
sarcasm but they want to pretend it's
not in order to attack me rather than
talk about guns so it still was a
learning experience for me the sarcasm
may not work well in tweets
oh for sure I I would also say there's
probably a third uh category there of
people who are typically not terminally
online like a lot of us are so we
understand the humor we understand your
point because of you know just
the discussions we have regularly on the
internet sure but people who just peruse
and can have uh somebody like Donald
Trump Jr uh kind of
Echo a sentiment against what we are
saying or what you said to make it look
bad is
it makes sense that you got the Flack
you did I agree I wanted to say that I
as somebody from Tennessee
um not originally here from here but who
lives here now and who has a little one
who goes to a school very similar to the
one that um
the tragedy happened at yeah I
you made a very valid point and I wish
that my state would do something more
than what we're getting from our
Representatives I'm with you Jason I'm
with you appreciate the call hey man
have a good one all right Jason from
Tennessee let's take just a very quick
break and I'm going to take more calls
so stay stay with us on the Discord if
you'd still like to get on we'll take
the quickest of breaks and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's hear from some more people of
course we do this on the Friday show you
can follow uh you can uh talk to me as I
guess is what I'm saying by uh signing
up for the Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go next to Kevin from
Philly Kevin from Philly welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
Kevin from Philly you've got to accept
my invitation my friend
there he is Kevin welcome
hi
um I was just wondering you know we've
heard recently more stories from Donald
Trump with grown men with tears in their
eyes yeah the latest one is like that
DeSantis came to him crying about an
endorsement
right do you think it's at least
possible that Trump maybe just wears too
much cologne or has very bad breath and
that's why the young men constantly have
tears in their eyes but it's just listen
mortar issue I'm as confused as you are
as to why grown men are regularly
bursting into tears around Donald Trump
and maybe you're right that it's like a
cologne type thing maybe it's a bad
breath thing honestly though I think the
most likely scenario is Trump's just
making it up
all right agree to disagree you
genuinely think people are crying but
you want to find the reason why
I don't know we'll see do you believe
for a second that DeSantis cried in
front of trump
no of course not I don't either it just
doesn't I don't even think the
conversation happens no you will I know
I mean I that's a good question did
santis ask Trump for I mean maybe the
endorsement request was made through
intermediaries it seems reasonable
DeSantis would ask for an endorsement
yeah I do wonder if if the primary does
come down to them there was this
commercial where DeSantis like was
reading a book about the wall and Trump
to his child and it's just this this
sycophantic suck up commercial to Trump
and it would be so interesting if that
popped back up if it was a primary
between them just to show like how like
subservient Ron DeSantis was to Trump
I'm gonna look for that that sounds that
sounds interesting I'm gonna also a few
years ago Ron DeSantis pronounced his
name Ron DeSantis which I find strange
to change how you say your name at age
40. I think that should make a comeback
DeSantis yeah all right Kevin from
Philly appreciate the call
thanks all right there he goes why don't
we go next to Jason from Virginia Jason
from Virginia welcome to the program
hey David how's it going it's going well
hey uh just uh following up about that
uh tweet controversy how do you feel
about uh getting acknowledged by Donald
Trump Jr and potentially the Taliban
well listen here's something that's
fascinating Donald Trump Jr and the
Taliban were able to find Common Ground
they really didn't like my tweet about
gun safety
um now Don Jr didn't like it because he
falsely claims and whether he believes
it or not that I'm blaming the kids who
died for the shooting which of course
I'm not I'm blaming the politicians who
send thoughts prayers and do nothing
else the Taliban liked I'm sorry didn't
like what I said
but their context was that I'm just I
think they use the term Zionist which
for them just means Jew they took the
anti-semitic approach so so I mean
listen politics I guess makes strange
bedfellows Don Jr and the Taliban
uniting against David Pacman it is it's
not the way I expected the week to go I
admit
I I couldn't believe it and then you
know reading just all the hateful
comments just uh you know but it made me
realize that what we see online isn't
relevant you know or representative of
the real world right in what sense but
just like uh you know uh the the online
audience is maybe more Amplified and you
know oh yeah maybe the general
population feels right and you know
what's funny is in the last few days
I've been out usually like when I go to
the grocery store one or two people
recognize me or if I'm in a restaurant
like one person will recognize me or
whatever it's like they all just come up
to me they have no idea about the
controversy like that you know it's like
every five seconds I'm getting a tweet
but out there it's sort of like most
normal people are just kind of Behaving
normally
I'm very good because some of the
comments were threatening in a way that
was concerning to me so hopefully of
course yeah and there's actually there's
a number of law enforcement
investigations already into those uh you
you might be shocked to hear
wow yeah all right well thank you so
much all right there's Jason from
Virginia great to hear from you why
don't we go next to Melody from misery
Melody from Missouri welcome to the
program uh you've been on before right
or am I not remembering correctly
yes I'm the one who spoke about the uh
drag controversy I'm the drag king
that's right welcome
hello
so my partner is trans and with all
these anti-trans sentiments going around
and Missouri being one around there's
actually a protest in Jeff City today
um where do you think it would be safe
for us to go that's in the South my
partner has health issues and we need to
move somewhere warm and oh man I'm kind
of like all these Southern maybe
Southwest I don't know but we're we're
kind of lost as to what to do so there's
a couple different ways to go about this
and you know it's really this has to be
your choice but if you said I want to be
in the South but somewhere that is kind
of like safer for Trans people I guess
we would say you know one of the things
that there's there's a couple things to
consider one is what laws have been
passed regarding everything from trans
bathrooms to school stuff if it's
relevant to you Etc so so like one is
like what is the legislation and then
the other thing is culturally what's
going on and that really varies way more
within States it can vary significantly
so like for example in Miami
my sense is that Miami itself and to
some degree probably Miami Beach
culturally are very trans friendly that
being said there are state level Florida
laws that you may see and say that I
don't like so I'm not up on all of these
details in order to be able to say Hey
you know here's where here's where you
should go but I think there's a couple
of different things to look at which
include cultural questions when there's
kids involved it's educational and other
things as well as what are the laws that
the states have passed with regard to
these issues
and we're looking at something like New
Mexico or Arizona possibly there's a job
I could transfer to but like yeah
Arizona is interesting Arizona is
interesting because the state has become
much more blue even though there's a lot
of crazy people there as evidenced by
the fact that that Kerry Lake almost won
but there's parts of it that are correct
correct me if I don't hold me to this
but like I think Tucson for example is
becoming quite a left-leaning city and
I've spent some time down there and
really enjoyed it so you've really got
to look at the details
well we're kind of in a blue spot in a
red state right now we're in Kansas City
so
um or which we've got lots of gay
friendly and trans-friendly places that
we go to but if you look at Missouri at
large and it's kind of getting different
thing it's the state versus local and
then the culture versus law thing yeah
listen I'm sure you will end up making
the best decision for your family but I
know it's a tough situation
thank you so much all right Melody from
Missouri
great to hear from you let's go to
Justin from Utah Justin from Utah you
know most of our Utah callers just
happen to be Mormons even though I know
Utah is filled with people who aren't
Mormons uh and oftentimes Utah callers
are very interesting welcome Justin what
can I do for you
David yeah so I was born LDS I'm no
longer LVS just just for the record okay
um yeah obviously I live in a in a very
red State
um with regard to
um you know the gun control uh debate
and and so on I often hear that you know
we need more we need more Heroes right
um versus uh stricter gun control I I
liken that too
if we were able to stop cancer no one
ever suffers from the disease again
right by that logic the best solution is
to
um you know instead hire more doctors
rather than actually cure cancer right I
think that's a very interesting analogy
which is rather than more good guys with
guns to fire back at the bad guys with
guns but make clear by the time the
police get there that they're the good
guy not the bad guys of the police
shouldn't shoot them why don't we just
try to reduce the number of shootings
that even start to begin with I think
it's an apt analogy
Dyson
anything else today Justin
you know I see that online all the time
um you know it's it's a common talking
point you know arming teachers it just
it's ridiculous I I don't understand
where the disconnect is on on that other
side do you do you have kids Justin
I do would you I mean I don't know what
kind of school they go to but if a
school they went to Armed teachers would
you pull them from the school
I would consider it tell me I mean a lot
of times with these things it's like
easier said than done you know the
logistics can be complicated and then
you've got to move kids who have an
established social group like I'm not
pretending it's easy but it's at least
something you would think about
yeah absolutely and I I would have the
means to homeschool if I if I wanted to
right so you know it's yeah it's very
troubling though out of curiosity you
said you you're like former LDS are you
no longer a believer in the doctrine or
you are no longer part of an organized
LDS church but you're still sort of like
a believer of the doctrine
I am not a believer in any organized
religion okay
yeah
um
yeah interestingly you know my my mother
would not go to church she would drop us
off
oh is that right yeah at the at the end
of uh you know as we got older we would
walk in one door and go out the other
and go hang out for a while okay so
interesting
all right my friend well listen great to
hear from you appreciate your insights
on your question
take care all right there is Justin from
Utah uh very very interesting to hear
from you let's go next to Dylan from
Georgia Dylan from Georgia welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
Dylan from Georgia you were on but
you've got to select the correct audio
device
hey David can you hear me yeah now I can
cool last time I was on we had a I
sounded like a robot was speaking I
don't know if you remember that well
that happens with a lot of callers
yeah well I've been a member for a while
and I'm it's great to talk to you
um I just had a kind of two questions
um the first one was
I don't know how much research you've
done into it but what are your thoughts
on the willow project being approved in
Alaska and um kind of how does that make
you feel with the contrast of all of Joe
Biden's promises about you know trying
to combat the climate crisis and more
electric cars and tax incentives for
electric when I read that I think the
willow project would produce the
equivalent of two million gas powered
cars yeah so I don't know how much you
read about that so here I have a bunch
of Articles bookmarked to read and the
insanity on Twitter this week made it so
I didn't get to from the little I've
read so far I'm very concerned about it
I want to learn more and maybe next week
I'll do like more of a deep dive segment
on it but I'm certainly I'm certainly
quite concerned about it from what I'm
from the little I've read so far
yeah yeah I've it it concerned me a lot
too
um and I you know I've been reading a
lot of I don't know if you know who Nate
Higgins is but he has a smaller smaller
YouTube channel about um
what he calls I guess the meta crisis
which is just this feeling that
everybody has that something is wrong
and we don't quite know how to address
it he does a good job of kind of
consolidating that but he just mostly
talks about the climate stuff in the
sense that
you know we need a cultural change not
necessarily making things more efficient
and even the drive to try to make things
efficient as quickly as we would need to
right in order to combat this stuff is
almost counterproductive because of the
things that we would use to construct
all of these green technologies rely on
fossil fuels and also you know it's just
it's a cultural shift that we have to
make and you know I guess it starts at
the individual level you know I try to
cycle but that's that's pretty much all
I can do at this point is just cut back
as best I can and I'm sure you're like
you're not you're not flushing your
toilet 10 to 15 times which I'm sure
helps
you know I'm I'm trying you know I'm at
eight right now I'm really trying to put
it down to five that would be good yeah
if we could only flush only five times
it'd be better yeah I just made a note
about Nate Higgins the content seems
interesting I'm gonna check it out
yeah yeah definitely yeah thanks David
all right Dylan from Georgia great to
hear from you let's go to Casey from
Kansas Casey from Kansas welcome to the
program oh what can I do for you today
hello
uh just you know more heavy stuff given
the recent you know
shooting that happened yeah
so Tucker Carlson recently had a segment
called
trans killer the trans movement is
targeting Christians following the
Nashville shooting do you think
journalism quotation marks that fear
monger's marginalized groups with such a
broad brush
should be illegal in a way
oh man what Germany or other European
countries would have well there's a
number of questions there because first
of all you're using journalism in quotes
legally Tucker Carlson doesn't do
journalism he does commentary so then
the question is a broader one which is
can can you know so it's more like in
the category of this might be satire
this might be sensationalism this is it
is the I think we really need legal
experts to weigh in on what even could
be done before we can even really weigh
in as to what should be done because
it's such a difficult question to answer
but I know exactly what you're saying
which and and listen
scapegoating is not a new technique
right now the trans Community is being
heavily scapegoated from all around I
hope it doesn't last forever but of
course when it goes away they'll move on
to the next group but you're asking some
really complicated questions that we
really need the legal world to answer to
answer for us excuse me
okay yeah I I don't know I wish there
was just something that could be done
because you know they call themselves
Fox News
and they make it seem like there's a
little bit of credibility when there's
really none but then they get sued and
then they go oh listen Tucker Carlson's
an Entertainer he uses Hyperbole and
exaggeration and blah blah blah you
can't hold them accountable nobody
should believe that what he says is
factual that's under oath in court what
they say and then on TV they pretend
like it's news now I'm with you Casey
okay well that's all I had all right
Casey from Kansas great to hear from you
that is all the time I have for today
great to hear from a lot of new and
repeat callers we will take calls again
and I look forward to hearing from many
more of you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's hear from some of you through the
Friday feedback segment where emails
Facebook comment YouTube comments smoke
signals telegrams Twitter replies all
sorts of communications with the show
may be featured on Fridays if you just
want to keep it simple and send an email
you can email info davidpackman.com I
have to admit this first message I don't
understand if this is from a Nazi or
from someone warning me about Nazis and
saying they have taken over the message
is as follows the weak fear the swastika
you all had your chances to deal with
this you dropped the ball we told you
for years we are everywhere and
eventually we would have to come out
well here we are now it's our time to
deal with these Weimar conditions
welcome to national socialism is this a
Nazi saying we have now taken over
because you didn't stop us or is this an
anti-nazi saying because you didn't stop
them the Nazis are now here
I genuinely have no idea
someone else knows what that message is
about
please let me know the anti-trans
movement continues and it continues
plaguing our YouTube channel user desro
QC says thank God for people like
Michael Knowles and Matt Walsh these are
anti-trans guys from the daily wire
fighting against the groomers who are
aiming their filth at our children we
are way past being polite and tolerant
with you bunch of degenerates trying to
indoctrinate confuse and mutilate kids
uh I don't know
what this person is talking about and as
I've said before
it seems as though no one is aiming
anything at children but we do have
things that exist which parents can
decide I will bring my kid to that
or I won't bring my kid to that and that
that's the freedom I thought the right
wing advocated for I thought that's
exactly what they wanted it's very
confusing rated ARG has a different view
about the anti-trans Hysteria and says
let's find a small marginalized group of
harmless people and really stomp on them
and make their lives miserable just to
show how big and strong and brave we are
you know this reminded me it's a very
good point this reminded me of Arnold
Schwarzenegger's recent video 12-minute
video which was it dealt with
discrimination of all kinds and
certainly you could tell that he was
pushing back against the anti-trans
rhetoric but it was also pushing back
against anti-Semitism and one of the
great points that Arnold made
referring to his own father who was a
Nazi sympathizer was all of these
movements these groups these coalitions
based on hate they end up being losers
at the end of the day they you never
look back at them and say those were the
winners the people who opposed women
voting
we don't those were the losers they they
hindered obvious progress in the United
States the Nazis in World War II of
course the anti-gay people who for 20
years shouted about too many if you let
two men marry next thing you know people
will be allowed to marry horses
they're losers they are and when you
look at this comment which is it's not a
very big thing big and I'm by big I mean
Alpha right to choose the weakest people
and to say that's who we're going to go
after excellent comment and I couldn't
uh couldn't agree more
um here's a comment about critical race
Theory
this individual why am I why am I Mr
Pink says the issue with critical race
theory is that it teaches the idea that
systemic racism is a thing when it is
not no one on the right wants to stop
the teaching of History they hate the
lies about it also history is complex
take the issue of slavery after slavery
was banned many still worked for their
owners why why didn't they pursue a new
career and become landowners because
many were fine in the position they were
in that last part is pretty crazy the
reason
some slaves continued working for their
owners when they were technically freed
was that there was still all sorts of
between the lines discrimination that
was allowed and was happening and
because many of those folks in their
individual situations didn't really have
much of a choice with what money were
they going to go and buy land
it doesn't make any sense but let's go
to the to the more important part it
teaches the idea that systemic racism is
a thing when it is not
listen there have been major advances in
the United States when it comes to
dealing with systemic racism of
different kinds and that has taken place
to different degrees we still have a
number of different systemic realities
in the United States that go above and
beyond the individual for example there
are still significant effects when it
comes to public transit in many cities
where the historically redlined
neighborhoods disproportionately
um uh represented by minorities are much
less well connected via public transit
that's a systemic issue that's a
systemic issue where in certain
neighborhoods you're going to have more
of an issue getting to jobs in certain
parts of the city
and the reason that that is the case is
because it is a Vestige of uh racial
racist redlining okay that's a systemic
issue that doesn't mean every aspect of
society is racist there have been a
number of interesting studies done where
the same resumes are submitted with
traditionally identifiably white
sounding names and black sounding names
no difference whatsoever when it comes
to the credentials and the white
sounding names are much more likely to
get an initial interview that's a
systemic issue you could be your the
idea is you're just disqualified but
because of a name that is stigmatized
with a particular race you're less
likely to even get the opportunity to
prove yourself in an interview that's a
systemic issue
now that doesn't mean that there haven't
been great improvements made as well so
the idea that there are no systemically
racist issues doesn't make much sense
Gerald says I wish every Republican
doing an interview would be asked
explain what critical race theory is and
explain what woke is yeah me too we've
talked about this before when they are
asked to explain critical race Theory
they usually spit out it teaches white
kids that they are bad because they're
white I missed that day in class and
when you ask them about woke I mean last
week even Fox host Dana Perino said woke
can just be a feeling or a sense
um here's another question relating the
uh drag show stuff to I guess
irresponsible parenting this user user
says would you David hand the car keys
to your child and say go have fun go as
fast as you want this is equal to taking
your child to a drag show that escalated
pretty quickly no I mean listen in 16
years I will start teaching my daughter
how to drive
and I will teach her the rules of the
road and I will teach her about road
safety and she will have to go to
Driver's Ed and complete a number of
hours of driver training and all of that
and then I will still continue to
espouse the need to be careful when
driving and I can't think of any way
in which that relates at all to a drag
show I just I'm I'm really racking my
brain
and I'm not understanding how there's a
connection between learning to drive
safely
and taking a kid to a drag show maybe
someone can explain it to me
giddy one posted to the subreddit
about me saying no president has ever
been arrested that it is false
and I received a few of these messages
this particular post says President
Ulysses S Grant or if I were Trump I
would pronounce it Ulysses but it's
Ulysses S Grant was arrested in 1872 for
Dangerous driving he was fined and did
not contest the arrest or fine then
going on to say President Franklin
Pierce was arrested for running over a
pedestrian while driving his carriage in
Washington possibly drunk driving he was
arrested but released when his identity
became known so two things about this
it is absolutely the case that I
misspoke and I I wanted to say indicted
which I think would have made my comment
more accurate but my research suggests
that the Franklin Pierce story
is questioned what I've read conflicting
accounts and some say that it is not a
true story about Franklin Pierce
but I'm not sure but in any case it does
appear that Trump wouldn't be the first
president arrested but I believe from my
research it is accurate to say indicted
but we are going to continue looking
into it very very strongly
another post from the subreddit asks and
this this hits Home Folks
is social media just not worth it
it's so goddamned infuriating logging on
and seeing the most smugly brain dead
easily debunked BS get thousands of
likes and shares I gave up arguing with
them long ago because exactly zero of
them will change their minds as a result
and I'll just get agitated with the
stupidity while they fly back to the
flock to claim victory I know ignoring
these clowns won't make them go away but
man is it frustrating
I have said for a long time
I don't engage in social media arguments
now it's easy for me to say because I
have a platform where I can do much more
in an hour than in 10 hours arguing with
individuals on Twitter I understand not
everybody has that but my advice
continues to be I don't know that I
would either get involved with it for me
social media is I want to see what is
being said but it's not for them
starting to type furiously at people
that's I I believe it is an exercise in
frustration and I sympathize with that
completely we try on our platforms like
the very subreddit that this this
message is from we try to make it a more
positive and controlled environment we
don't allow you know direct harassment
and of course people can disagree we
don't allow slurs and these sorts of
things but at the end of the day
sometimes it's just wow your opinions
really aren't based in fact and there's
really nothing I can do about that and
that is certainly a sad thing but I
would agree with this person's view
ignoring won't make them go away but
arguing with them on Twitter won't make
them change their minds and so we have
to work in a different way we have to
work through campaigns we have to work
through activism and that is much more
effective than you know arguing with
someone on Tick Tock or whatever the
case may be get your messages in info
davidpackman.com or through any of the
other means that you can get in touch
with us we will have such a great bonus
show for you today and if you don't have
access to the bonus show because you're
not a member then we will be back on
Monday with a new podcast for you
thank you